this is the new Gucci thing I'm guessing
is the norm because the constant moves
so they had a very big mr. Gucci or mrs.
Gucci you know such the boy Fetty WAP
man had time to show you these jewels
first piece of jewelry a believable in
1738 piece on 17th today notice the crew
is actually a little company but it's
like the Lego researching that remark
that's like the find the fine wine right
there you know San 1738 and Markham put
you know we just I just had thing you
just probably tied the twenty boys it
was especially good right here I
actually got this one my driver right
here 2016 Fetty WAPs or welcome to the
zoo so he drove my truck
all the way from New Jersey to
California California back to New Jersey
so I actually mentioned it in the song
flip phone that I did go Mercedes chain
from my chauffeur most recent piece Fat
Boy game I got this for my board Fat Boy
SSD know as a gift you on told me right
now if I'm in Jersey - I'm from New
Jersey so you know that's what we do we
family you know saying so they got that
Fat Boy game it was the first person in
New Jersey to ever break track plan so I
know my Lords he knows and I gave him
one of my cars - this is my life gift to
him you know I'm a whole dad I know
everybody gotta get they chain you know
saying he actually was the first person
that gave me an apartment while I was
doing music so I was living in his
my god my mom was like tripping on this
and then what's the money started coming
in I got my other DJ DJ bigger he liked
the Cuban so I'm the big Cuban he's like
the most famous DJ and Patterson and
James that's what we came so I felt like
it was an honor to have him you know I'm
saying come walk with me guys I started
my journey from Patterson we brought
from the same city 35 before 2000 this
is like my first tennis piece right here
the smaller it is the more money you
have to pay unless you don't know that
so I think this is like 2025 thousand
dollars or there's only because I got a
flawless diamonds in it got my favorite
bracelet I can't even remember the name
and you can say I wear my shoes cuz a
little time is missing but the chain I
had to this it was I won my first Cuban
Linx I bought myself growing up in
Paterson a Cuban chain like there's a
big dog this is one of the pieces where
I kind of like stepped up my okay
I call this the big rock you're saying
like drew stone was in there versus how
this one got like six or eight stone was
going across you know I was like the
first person to start dr. Thomas on it I
wanted to do something different cuz I
didn't want to put a pendant on it so I
want to wear it like it's a dog chain
besides a Gucci man he actually was the
one that inspired this so he said
running his songs call him a dog he was
like a $150,000 dog collar actually did
say thousand dollars more
so this is my trophy to myself it's
pretty like some things that me it's
like full carries this is actually why
everything change I love this one so
much I'm not for sure about last time
was like 60
yeah these like the rocks that goes in
like the wedding rings yeah this is like
220,000 this is my to carry chain this
is like the big dog starting to carry up
the little you and then it goes up to
four carats and this one was like two
full you know favorite but I styled
protect and I first seen is what I seen
it and I was like you know why none of
those look like this was like only this
one looks like there's no other one
looks shines like this one this was like
I gotta have we had like a little mini
tour and the UK and I wanted to know
what time it was
and the UK when I went back home so when
I said to watch I'd never change so now
every time I wake up when I want to know
what I'm days in London a little bit
later so I got the big dog
just like my prized possession hey you
know a lot a lot of people don't got
this faded and baguettes on the face you
know sans ice a stout crazy anyway or
please do crazy crazy and this one was
like fifty or one of the robberies
I had a lot of Jerry on in the bow night
two years at one point I had like 45
chains or something I only wear like
three now I mean I don't have it all
along its own way he still wore the way
I got a lot of chains protective boom
just got a new delivery and might a
little bit more Jerry should look on
yeah it's a lot to accent it's pretty
swell yeah hey just got to drop off more
Cubans I got loads of love settings and
this one is actually some new [ __ ] that
I've seen before
hey this is actually the bigger version
of what I had so this would be the
bigger dog this is ridiculous man you
guys can see that this is like it's just
so what's going on what this is not it's
not a drill like this I mean there's no
holes in this so you're not losing
values
you keep awaiting you adding weight and
it's like a layer on top of it and you
then add the dogs on it makes it a lot
more expensive than your average
Cupidon necklace I don't know what if
you'd a number on this but I'm gonna
just take a wild guess and just say 85
to see one did we like to start accusing
before I got like the big one and then
he was like nah you can't do this I was
like the crossover from this to that but
then I started wearing others just again
eight Cuba's I had on oh it would be
different
[Music]
this is all the homies are here so I
bought like 30 of these dishes like 4500
BC or everybody pass them off you know
everybody got patients on a bling but
here next time I'll come back we're
gonna have the bullet treasure chest for
you guys it's gonna look like Gilligan's
Island in this [ __ ]
you know boy Freddy Rock 1730 the out
here wants to think of jeju that this
thing shine and i'm hearling like a
little big flashlight no sense
[Music]